what's up guys I'm Ryan right so today
I'm gonna be doing a let's play for the
first time for this channel the real
rejects people I've been asking that I
do them more often I've only
guest-starred on people like dan cybers
channel why go small for the first let's
play let's go all out with this game
called hatred hurt rude I'm gonna be
doing it by myself because I want to
experience this truly experience what
it's like game is so [ __ ] up alright
let's do this let's do this new game Oh
easy hard extreme let's go with hard
perform executions on people how you
need to replenish your health that's the
only way of healing here Wow alright
first kill
you guys ready to experience the purge
right here right now murdering it in his
room person slices throw I like you I
will leave the basements there we go
here we go ok I'm getting in a character
right now it's the best way to play any
game does feel like you're the character
seriously I hope I get like rip people's
heads off in this game so much
aggression so much anger out there in
this world my name is not important what
is important is what I am going to do oh
yeah [ __ ] some people up
feasting on its cooking I agree my whole
life is just cold of course this is the
time of vengeance like I would say let's
see how we can do this it's time for me
to die die die dodge no I want to do an
execution on someone [ __ ] yeah I hate
always hated this garden this was always
a disgusting garden yeah I know I never
liked that car either games giving me a
hard-on where are you where are you
people
oh you [ __ ]
what don't run away don't run away don't
run away I'm coming after you just gonna
chase you the whole game just gonna
chase you
yeah oh now there's three of them
Wow my mom would love this game
I have a really good aim I've never been
this good at aiming before in games
cops
died everyone died
oh come on man you can do better than
that I'm a serial killer every everyone
that the dad sounds like that man now
yeah Pig
whoa whoa whoa Wow
can't tell you the amount of cops that
have pissed me off in my life got a
speeding ticket on Glendale Boulevard
once it's like dude I was barely going
above the speed limit and this game is
giving me that opportunity once I
remember how to play this game [ __ ]
cops you and your your Donuts or
whatever it is you cops do ha ha ha
kicked him I gotta kill more innocent
people because I'm running out of Health
just the worst part is when you get
really engrossed in this game and you
forget that there's a camera recording
you and you're like I'm genuinely
enjoying murdering all these people
right now
oh oh oh hell no
oh hell nah no no I'm gonna I'm gonna do
this one properly this time that was
just getting my feet wet that was just
getting my dick with that was just
getting that [ __ ] wet now it's time to
orgasm die people so fast it can be it's
okay I believe in God and I know that if
I ask for forgiveness for my sins I'm
going to heaven still it's one of the
rules scoping out the scene scoping out
the scene
this looks like my neighborhood and
that's what I used to look like no way
you can Jack a cop's vehicle
hahaha I just bagged a baby with God wow
I'm a horrible driver
I'm pretty sure the main character who
got drunk or is okay I'm getting out of
the car excuse me I like to murder you
please I want your gun I got my shotgun
let's blow someone's head off let's blow
someone's that up waste the party oh I
can waste the party alright
well one day we were just partying and
then a man came in with a shotgun and
sort of blowing us all what maybe I'm
getting too into this okay there's more
efficient guns to kill a bunch of people
the best part about it is you're just
shooting people who can't fight back
really except for the human shields the
pigs do I will judo kick all you [ __ ]
I just wanted to do that
I wasted my last bullet on you you
didn't even die right away it's how you
do it yes
Oh what this guy thinks he's a hero guy
thinks he's a hero oh look at these cops
I clearly need to kill more innocent
people because I'm running a long life
cleanse the police station
no we're gonna go one more time we're
gonna go one more time this is just like
this is just like my upbringing coming
after you buddy come on
Kim I keep running keep running failed
the slaughter the police house last time
I know I know it doesn't matter you just
don't a circle it is all no how could I
leave you alive yeah I just might kill
some cops is all
all right PO you rated [ __ ] Ritt da
pigs your and aft
it's for when you showed up to court a
hundred two eighty [ __ ] days after I
[ __ ] already it was like yo just let
the ticket go I'm sorry I wasn't wearing
the seatbelt doesn't mean you have to Oh
son of a [ __ ] well guys I just played
hatred that game was wasn't as bad as I
thought it would be I felt that it was a
game that I felt that it was a game that
is it's a game blood is spilling
throughout my veins right now I got to
admit hate to admit this I'm gonna get a
lot of hate for this but hey what can I
do but be honest I enjoy playing that
game I like killing all these people in
the cops it's just a bunch of dumb
civilians in the way of my purification
anyway yeah
feel like masturbating now I'm gonna go
do that instead